bienvenue dans le studio diagonale tv à
l'issue de cette ronde 7 des
championnats de france 50 en 2015 je
suis avec un super grand maître tigran
gharamian salut tigran salée face à des
scènes alors super tournoi pour toi hein
parce que c'est quand même pas mal tu as
fait une défaite quand même moins bon
c'est un tournoi difficile et l'effort
donc ça peut arriver
alors il reste les quatre onglets plus
important donc on verra bien on verra
bien en tout cas super résultat
aujourd'hui parce que je suis content de
gagner donc toute façon à ces moments là
à ce moment là la victoire est un très
important
effectivement il va rester quatre ondres
après cette victoire replace tout près
de la tête donc déjà aux mains pour un
podium était très bien placé et pourquoi
pas pourquoi pourquoi pas mieux vous
faire tuer là t'es pas tu n'es pas hors
course et donc les partis qui vont
suivre un enjeu important
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce serait
exactement ça alors la verte à partit
donc c'est aujourd'hui face à sébastien
mazet et puis on verra peut-être après
la portière côté comment tu vois la
suite et donc alors c'est parti alors
que les blancs monts comment comme
j'imagine tous les joueurs du national
qu'ils essaient de gagner avec les
blancs dont comment donc ce n'est pas
une exception que j'ai le 4e cas donc
toujours que la france toujours en
général oui oui ça m'arrive de jouer des
quatre cavaliers 3 je pense car à ce
moment là maintenant c'est très
compliqué de jouer un seul coup ya très
très peu de joueurs dans le top 10 qui
ne joue que qu'un seul coup comme le 4
adams où il est plus dans le top 10 mais
il varie un petit peu pour essayer
d'augmenter les chances de placer une
préparation
où les idées travail il faut se fier est
révolu alors donc il répond par oui mais
oui donc 5 en général sébastien il joue
aussi la sicilienne mais quand
généralement il joue aussi la verrerie
mans dans ce tournoi là plusieurs fois
il a déjà avec 4,5 donc que c'était
paris n'était pas une surprise ce qui
attendait la préparation devrait pas
brillant donc avalé trois quarts à
laisser si ce qu'a laissé six trous b5
et le cabinet epsy fini l'espagnol s'est
plus jamais personne n'a joué tout est
jouable à tout est jouable
tout est jouable maintenant mes
cavaliers psy havane m6le l'approchent
la plus directe et la plus solide et
donc les noirs attaque le pion il pose
une question en disant quand est-ce que
tu laisses où tu es tu le donnes on peut
faire plusieurs coups il ya 103 ajouté
trois oui une personne il joue aussi
bien petit rat qu'on peut aussi jouer à
détroit et avec l'idée de ne pas forcer
les choses un peu ne pas vous forcément
jouer pour l' avantage mais essayer
d'avoir une partie de ces pièces est ici
celui qui joue mieux il finit par
l'emporter il faut qu'il n'ya pas
l'importer exact ils ont donc cédé 3
c'est pas pour forcément l'avant un
avantage mais il partit donc toi tu as
choisi un journal je joue des trois mais
là pour cette partie là j'avais j'avais
envie de voir de temps en temps j'aime
bien entre eux n'ont cessé dans la
finale de la berlinoise pour bien me
rendre compte qu'il ya absolument rien
qu'elle choisit de rock et donc ou petit
robe et cavaler pour leucate et noir
peuvent jouer autre chose mais c'est le
direct un corps donc élan nouveau centre
oui si on veut jouer les lignes simples
on peut jouer des tours aux 1 et puis ne
pas avoir grand chose mais il vaut mieux
jouer ça pour zouker c'est une des
lignes principales nos cavaliers des six
qui l'utilisé ici encore plusieurs co
existent mais fou processus et compense
donc ça l'apprendre variantes de
chronique face à castres offre
exactement exactement donc ces lots
problème d échec actuel où les noirs qui
avaient fait des six est une des
ouvertures et qui permettent de ne pas
se prendre des grosses préparations
l'ordinateur ne n'est pas capable de
calculer nous comprendre les finales
donc il est très peu utile dans la
berlinoise où tout l'effort des top 10
ou même top 50 beaucoup de joueurs
jouent ça parce que ça ça évite un peu
salée grosse préparation de l'adversaire
- ces vidéos ordinateurs aussi oui bien
sûr qu'il ya toujours des préparations
mais c'est un peu moins que dans les
sicilienne par exemple dont quatre ans
et six en option et puis et puis enfin
le 5 mai cavaliers 20 f 5 pouces assez
connu hélas en échange de darwin ont
connu c'est un peu l'idée donc les
blancs de cannes l avantage de père de
fou ce qui est pas génial oui mais en
contrepartie ils ont fait un tri minh
majorité un quatre contre trois les
quatre pions ici oui font face à
uniquement trois quarts ce qui leur
permettra peut-être un jour de créer un
puits ont passé un peu plus facilement
que par exemple aurait pour les noirs
qui ont quatre pions à l'aide d'un mais
ça va être un peu plus compliqué de ski
sont doublés mais le gros problème des
blancs c'est que ce pion ans le 5 il est
allé un peu loin
oui et ce pion là il faut à la fois le
protéger et ce pion en lançant aux cinq
ça laisse plein de cases blanches est un
peu affaibli
donc le fou case non des noirs il est
fait en pièces assez fortes mais aussi
ceux qui ont été enlevés quatre l'énorme
jouerait pas autant la berlinoise en
tout cas il est aussi il faut souligner
que le roi noir qui est des rockets non
ça il faut pas oublier c'est aussi
extrêmement important et parfois il va y
va jusqu'en bcsa oui oui donc les noirs
choisi soit le cachet par mme bessette
en jouant b6 coup d'essai 3c 8 ou le
laisser au centre donc comment les
problèmes des noirs c'est donc le roi
qui est légèrement mal placé et suite à
ceux ci les deux tours noirs ne sont pas
encore moi c'est pas si simple
désactiver la connexion connectés donc
ma connectez vous
donc je vais cavani c3 on augmente
simple coup de développement elle si les
noirs peuvent jouer minimum cinq ou six
coups qui sont tout à fait corrects ils
jouent un rôle à jouer
lui il a remis son huit partis de
l'autre côté il va en tester un peu plus
plus agressif on va dire b6 coup d'essai
3 arrive en basket c'est par un peu plus
agressif mais pas de lait que le roi en
beauce est le pion à vii peut être un
peu attaquées avec les cailloux comme
cavalier je sais que tu es là du moins
le roi pour depuis maintenant les
lambourdes problème c'est si je les
noirs arrivent à résoudre le problème
avec la tourache suit en général disons
qu'un problème quoi et bien évidemment
il devrait toujours faire attention pour
battre les blancs puis jouer des g4
c'est que la majorité de cons sont mis
en rage quoi donc si les pions blancs
arrivants f4 gk tâche 3g 2 en général ce
sont ces considéré comme un avantage
les jouets h3c entre manger un coup
utile dans toutes les positions
donc la grande ligne ch 5 mais c'est pas
ce qui a été joué donc h 5 h si c'est
bon fawcett joué et ai joué pendant très
très longtemps donc il a joué le fou
aussi poussé aussi correct donc la
grande une grosse vague andine ses
cavaliers g5 food et c'est quelque chose
comme ça mais ici on laisse aller
des soirs je voudrais 700 membres jouve
c4 en général c'est considérer qu'il
faut pas donner le fou le case blanche
si facilement
je suis peut-être ça se tient mais en
tout cas ce qui est ce qui est sûr c'est
que après c'est les blancs qui joue pour
tranquillement pour la rendre la cour
donc voilà j'ai tenté un b3 je suis pas
con bien sûr que ce soit un très bon
coup de joaillerie pour nous jouer en
place du cahier je crois est parfois
arrivé de dire oui évidement tout et
tout est jouable tout est donc là ok b3
avec l'idée d'empêcher des fous ckt tout
donc là il a tout de suite utiliser ce
souk ou quatre ans alors je m'en fous
des quatre voyages hatta cavaliers le
cavaly vent eu 2 ou 2 au 6 juin quatre
fous destin qui est était gênant et puis
s'attaquent les deux cavaliers donc j'ai
pas eu un faux pas protégés par il y
avait eu assez vite embêtant donc sauf
qu'en général je me suis tout à fait
typique socar valley qui se replace en
f4 pour justement attaqué le fond aussi
sont là je le fous des cinq pense qu'on
comme il a joué dans la partie c'est
tout à fait correct menacent de ne pas
déclasser la structure de pian et qui
est à voir car cavaliers presque éternel
cinq experts assez gênant bon j'avais
plusieurs courbes aux gens qui avaient
des quêtes peut-être end les échanges ne
sont pas forcément à chaud peut même pas
malheureusement parce qu'il ya échange
et oui il ya tous ces trois gars y voit
la flandre et ces deux variantes
pourquoi c'est pas possible
voilà il m'a parlé et on s'est mis à
part le fait qu'ils compères du matériel
tout de suite c'est pas forcément une
très bonne idée d'échangé si facilement
de plus il faut mieux éviter des
changements l'import bas parfois des
mois voire mettre du temps avec nos
cavaliers avec 5 ils vont le set j'ai si
c'est tout donc de les changer trop vite
c'est pas une bonne idée mais oui bien
sûr concrètement aux pertes humaines
donc j'ai joués par dany beaudoin
longtemps que j'ai cités j'hésitais
entre cavaliers
ça fait ça fait du repli oui mon mais ce
message via l'option basse
libérez déploré ce cavalier en f3 en
général ils bougent donc s'ils restent
là c'est pas une réponse ils font trop
aussi du classement il ya réaction
typique sont par exemple font prendre
des deux il aurait pu jouer ça fou prend
des deux faut prendre des deux parce que
c'est considéré que les fous avec les
fous couleur opposée à en général dans
la berlinoise c'est correct one ok c'est
pas très dangereux je m'attendais qui
joue ça mais je pense que c est guéri
mais peut-être c'est encore jouable
c'est pas nul en tout cas un moment
alors qu'est ce qui nous a fait là il va
jouer à 5 mais il y avait un coût très
intéressant que pendant longtemps j'ai
calculé c'était cavale et des quatre
mois pas mal j'ai fini par trouver un
coup intéressant là dessus car certes
nice à vienne malgré cela on laisse
prendre
oui prix masina lyzel vais devoir c'est
ça l'idée c'est de décharger ce cavalier
et de libérer un peu la position d une
baignoire et salaires des très hautes et
très intéressant mais j'ai deviné en
baisse et ici je pense que ça va en fait
après les échanges je vois clairement le
pion aux 5 n'est pas celle c'est un très
bon piont même si concrètement c'est
encore un peu pas par les paraphes 4 on
est juste je trouve oui mais les
dauphins sont bien placés les la tour va
arriver lors voir le roi va tout de
suite avancé t on le sait les tours au
total des primes des cadres c'est pas un
très bon au vocable fou c3 est l'astuce
est dans cette position il ya plusieurs
idées mais parce que j'ai eu pendant
longtemps j'ai hésité à cavaler de jouer
cavalier le 2 bon c'est pas du tout la
partie c'est une allégorie pour enfermer
le coup franc est ici plusieurs que ce
nom ce soit n'est peut-être pas le
meilleur
je vous ai déjà un peu entre un serbe et
khadir et la 4f qu'ils étaient là oui
pour ce qui passe à foie gras mais après
je l'aï découvert qu'il y avait autour
des 8 et 6 et tout géniteur des huit
gardes fous sort pour que le fou à la
soit attaqué le cabinet puis j'ai fini
par trouver une mine très très bonne
ligne donc il faut revenir à un ton
différent et donc collé le cavalier de 2
j'ai fini par trouver le coup cavani f5
et quand je trouvais ce coup là j'étais
assez assez content donc c'est là le
principal
oui bon ceci ne va rien ne s'est pas du
tout d'abord orientaux donc là il doit
prendre en la tour 1 1
il prend la bourde est là et la c4 très
important d'abord c4 d'abord sekkat la
fag le fou n'a pas trop de casse
j'aurais aussi un cavalier pranger cet
échec
ah oui puisqu'on prend d'abord est donc
si les noirs c'est 30 vention une
quinzaine ouah ça me permettra peut-être
de faire un échec même tout de suite
avec neuf le fou qui sera en prise de
groix dès cet été le bon coup à 2,7 et
ici j'ai j'allais jouer cavalier f3 donc
je pense que dont j'ai une qualité de
moi mais pour un champion mais j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une très très bonne
compensation quoi oui le kava les âges
s'inquiète si souffle ou g5 fois m6 on
n'a pas le sentiment sentiment que les
rives les blancs s'en fout du mal à
s'activer magie ça c'est un plaisir non
plus mais bon qu'à valider quatre c'est
peut-être pas un bon coup mais j'étais
obligé de regarder c'est digne d'un donc
j'étais assez content quand j'ai trouvé
était nul avec cavaliers 5 donc pas très
élégant et il a joué bon il pouvait
jouer caillage 4 c'est ce qu'il a dit
mais il a joué 1 à 5 à 5 voyages où il a
voulu appliquer sur cc
très bonne idée d'écrire des trois en
général dans la verdunoise à 5 à 4 et r
c'est typique
donc je suis obligé de chasser ce fou
ces trois sets franchissent le
foudroyant le 7 sept
je chasse l'autre fou aussi c4 donc je
reprends un peu les cases que j'ai tenus
facilement fournir le 6 et donc l'alger
presque une occasion de jouer j ai 4
n'est pas rosé et puis quand maillage
4,4 et en amérique a pu on arrive scène
et 1,5 parce que si cette majorité
avance et c'est peut-être la ligne
critique dans cette politique dont le
veau bloqué par g6 mais c'est pas très
grave
une fois que ce pion j'ai bougé en
général ça me donne des cases noires
comme celle ci c'est toujours ça donne
c'est une bonne chose pendant d'accord
mais j'ai fini par trouver une ligne qui
me plaisait pas ce côté j'ai quatre
cavaliers qui était le kf5 mais bon
c'est attrayant et donc je me suis dit
allez un coran ou docks où j'ai joué
j'ai joué cavalier aux 4,4 je me suis
dit bon cavalier bien placé et puis
peut-être ça me permettra de jauger ktef
quand il a joué 1 4 je pense que c'est
très bien joué mais sûre il continue et
cette vision là il est toujours là il
met de la pression gymnase de cochon et
menacent tout de suite donc four b2
c'était un peu la dernière occasion on
n'en a pas peur de leurs trois n'ont
jamais à 3 c'est pas très grave
bon c'est pas très grave peut-être c'est
pas dramatique pour les noirs mais en
tout cas une fois que ceux qui ont et
fixer et je sais que mon jeu se joue à
aller au centre et à l'est le roi - et
les noirs dans tout contre vous alors
que ici je suis obligé toujours
surveillée qui joue pas à bab et la
colonne qui domine et noir a6 et doubler
tour pour moi mais bon là ça va être
compliqué la c1 s'il est toujours ouvert
si vite il aurait déjà mieux que jamais
parce que dès qu'il sort il ya échec et
c'est fini et donc c'était quand je fais
les deux je sais que je savais que
c'était la dernière occasion de jouer g4
et donc il m'a empêchée par acheté voilà
ça affaiblit la ville fermée presque pas
si je me trompe pas on pouvait presque
pas facile de tout âge 4 gts à titre la
tour oui c'est très facile ou pourquoi
pourquoi nous voulons vraiment il faut
bien que je donc là j'ai fini par jouer
touré faisait un tour f d un donc bon je
prends la colonne j'empêche les
histoires de roide et c'est tellement il
a joué b6 ce qui est possible ce qui est
possible tout est possible qu'ils aient
souvent une structure pour la berline
peut-être un jour ces cinq mois ça j'ai
essayé de ne pas laisser m
donc j'ai fini par un peu avoir marre de
ces expansions il peut le faire même à
long terme des sept rois des vitres
assez vite
ok avec le faux bouge il faut toujours
faire attention parce que j'ai des coups
comme aussi ça peut-être pas
concrètement maintenant mais un jour ça
peut arriver mais il n'est pas si ce
n'est il y a une idée derrière toi
l'amour pur g7 l'office active et donkey
l'agefi par conduisait un peu avoir
marre de cette tension à l'aide d'armes
qui me bloquait un petit peu oui
donc j'ai joué car là les deux c3 pour
le savoir si ces menaces
car il attend la qu'avant et je
m'attendais à plusieurs à 3 mais comment
il a joué je pense que c'est correct
aussi même je m'attendais à trois fous
c1 et puis à troyes le fourreau vivre il
y avait peut-être une peur de ce que
ceux qui ont soif peut-être faiblesse
qui a peut-être
il a peut-être raison c'était compliqué
de savoir en tout cas difficile à savoir
donc un berbère
donc il prend tout reprend oui tout
reprend en choeur ils m'ont aussi je
prends de la tour c'est justement tout
reprend ça laissera des sept comme on
disait tout va et le roi parce que je
vois ce cachot mari soit fait sa voix à
l'europe à sortir et on est content
parce que sur en échec de nous
maintenant on va sur le bon côté
solidaires et je pense que l'on peut
plus où on peut oublier l'histoire de
l'avantagé encore oui parce que vous
annoncez ici al'avantage la paire de fou
compense largement la structure 1
exactement
donc du coup je dois prendre du fou pour
essayer de maintenir un peu ce roi qui
gêne tout le monde alors que le coût
naturel c'est de prendre
et donc maintenant une idée c'est de
remettre le tout sur une vraie case et
puis peut-être un jour préparés g4 et
tous et j'espère toujours qui sort pas
avec la tourache quel acteur je suis
reste un petit peu enfermé dehors je
crois qu'il a joué tout b4 qui était
très intéressant à tous les cadres qui
donne une base auront exactement c'est
ça l'idée de sortir parce que le fou
n'est pas mieux la queue
mais c'est justement avec les loups j'ai
joué tous b2b 2 et donc hallyday ces six
jours wall e set j'ai cavaliers à 2 et
voilà le cne là le fou est légèrement
gaz
il n'a pas une belle 15 ans on lui a
causé 5 5 mais c'est un permis à b4 et
non je veux dire c'est simple noir
doivent la wii voilà les noirs doivent
jouer c'est simple
et là je prends et puis je fais le même
manoeuvre crise et pousser un sou c'est
un celi d un pouce et saintonge et son
essai de matt est si si jamais ça marche
ah oui et puis j'ai une bonne moitié un
petit peu les l'imposition noir donc
c'est un peu un succès donc voir si ce
n'est pas un bon coup en c3 ce qui est
un très bon coup voilà donc il a fait ce
qu'il fallait jouer c'est ce qu'on
attendait à cette couleur est donc là si
malheureusement si je prends des
fouilles à ses 5 et j'ai pas réussi à
comprendre comment je devais jouer
palace par la suite donc j'ai pris du
cavalier c5 contrôler quasiment pendant
que grâce au tube des cases blanches et
vise à permettre aux recettes et il ya
des problèmes exactement
donc je prends du carbone y ait l'idée
c'est si les nuages ou c5 pour essayer
d'avoir le cavalier en d4 léger cavalli
b5
non c'est une idée assez basique parce
que le roi est coupée à l'est puis on
sait cette cinématique est donc ici ça
va pas moi je m'attendais qui jouent la
hausse est dans cette position royal 7
était le coup que je considérais comme
le principal pour moi et on sait gérer d
un chèque échecs ses cinq essais un peu
et b4 peut-être une reine meunière des
tours à huit qui arrive très vite à on
développe la tour en laisse le pion oui
mais la torah attaquera pour garder
peut-être alors roy et ses sept jeunes à
travailler avec son échec alors 6-5 pour
pas
ça va pas à la rue et b4 et à tour à un
mythe par exemple qui attaquent fois oui
le foot attaque et d'un gilet beige et
de faire une considéré les pme et à kehl
m en lasse les noirs peuvent déjà
prendre l'option maîtres leroy 1,8
correctement maintenant le pion on a
fait reculer le cavalier c'est pas poli
et puis en tout cas on a développé ce
jour c est maintenant à tous et à grain
c'est ici pions c4 et serait tombé ici
vous perdre tout de suite longtemps
prise la tour arrive sur la sauce ou la
quatrième pour faire pression sur la
deuxième si on n'a rien à dire non à son
bien et pas de problème donc moi
j'allais jouer plutôt phocéen est fou g5
comme on avait et il m'a un peu surpris
avec un coup cavaliers au 7e jeu cette
fois nous pas non plus un mauvais coup
c'est je pense que la position a
tellement de ressources donc je joue
pendant longtemps je ne comprenais pas
vraiment l'idée est figé ci ne pas
revoir donc j'ai joué quand même fou
c'est un parce que je dois remettre ce
fou sur angers 5 pour menacer maths et
donc sont ils s étaient faux f5 mais
étonnamment il l'a passé un corps il
faut excellent date accéder exactement
moi j'ai trouvé une ligne c'était
peut-être encore jouable mais je pense
que c'est très proche de new wave ce à
quoi donc il a tenté l'autre coup qui
est intéressant mais c'est déjà les
légèrement octobre et 5
d'accord on peut de petites fautes mais
c'est plutôt panique à ce qu'il a vu que
mon prochain qu à leds rouges et 5 et il
bouge pas du tout donc s'était
légèrement un peu comme
je sentis c'était plutôt la panique mais
bon c'est probablement correct aussi un
est donc là ici j'ai sacrifié le pion
pour essayer d'avoir vraiment le maximum
d'initiatives donc sous g5 tu donnes le
pion c'est cats a baissé ses prix ce
prise sous ceccatty prendrions hélas
cavalli aux 4 et maintenant et donc
l'idée est très simple donc je vais
placer permanence et 5
oui ça bouffe laurence est toujours
j'essaie de garder le roi toujours
enfermés et puis la tour peut
potentiellement aller en a un à huit
fermes at et donc nous prendre la tour
en 1 h 8 si jamais ça s'est pas défendu
ici c'est très très peut-être savoir
mais c'est très compliqué ici je
m'attendais à foug aussi c'est à cavaler
des cinq qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
a joué aussi pour qu'on trouve assez
vite mais bon ça c'est pas si j'avais
passé qui se met dans une situation pas
si fou je vais juste améliorer tout le
monde et ça va ça va être horrible la
vallée des saints qui est peut-être bien
joué
alors là qu'avaient les 17 aller au
besoin je pensais que j'ai gagné tout de
suite mais j'ai joué tout un oui parce
que ça oui parce qu'on se dise au revoir
17 blessés voilà c'est ça oui les acquis
se passe d'ailleurs si un toit mais il a
tombé la vallée b si allah heureusement
way et le montreront montrer quand même
oui on noie dans cette si je veux éviter
l'échec
voilà six jours à 17 l'espérance à 120
cavaliers 17 et regardez le cavalier
attaque le roi contre la case 6 l'opion
contre la casse des le foot où ça ne
pourront être vus
venir soit en huit sont assez vite
imaginez on s'est vite et regardez le
très joli match du tournoi
échec et mat et c'est quand j'ai vu ces
lignes l'âge on voit clairement que l'
avantage de pions ne se voit pas les
deux pauvres doublaient sont ciblés
c'est pas difficile à bordeaux ne sait
pas si important que ça on se voit
quelques fois l'activité de 17% le
sacrificium m'a paru intéressant parce
que mais je pense qu objectivement il y
avait forcément une ligne où ça doit
tenir mais avec les avec notre cité
c'était très compliqué un cavalier de
beci se soucier de jouer ça sinon du
matin dans la cour on préfère la torah
donc oui donc - ici j'ai encore d'un peu
de choix mais j'ai joué fine et un au
tour à sept tours à 7 à lecavalier
contrôle à gaza mais le bon moment sur
une planète en catalan c7 est un pion
très important il peut pas le donner en
croit des six tombes l'autre tombe ou si
la sauce active tout tombe réactif on a
besoin de plus la casse des six aussi ça
fait tout de suite réagir si ce cavalier
peut sauter qu'il a joués roi 17 ans
croit 17 quasiment forcé un avocat va
laisser cinq échecs échec roi doit aller
assez vite et encore j'ai une très belle
condition tourne a l'impression que ça
doit s'y trouve un très joli coup l'a1
et la mode et j'avais vu de loin que
j'avais aussi et ouais mais je pense
qu'il ya quand même une ligne où ça
tient même en de 6,6 efforts alors
l'idée de 6 et pas de pousser le pur ans
et c'était entre autres
faux f4 veut jouer au fou là parce que
y'a rien on peut pas défendre et c'est
le pion c7 le pion le plus important si
je prends le pion c7
j'aurai toujours une très bonne
initiative et surtout tu ramasses sur le
septième est faible à saint-pierre à
bord d'un réseau les maths donc aussi
c'est l'idée donc voilà c'est en
sacrifiant pour me busch au maire au fou
donc ici le problème
bon je ne voyais pas comment je jouais
après roanne évite par exemple
alors s'il faisait roi baiser pour ça
j'ai réfléchi que j'ai encore tout
retourné chez grasset victoire trichet
voilà c'est 8 29 4 oui et coralie des 5
hayek avait baissé mais tu joie pour et
roy bennett est en fait je n'ai pas un
truc ça serait possible
satyam est ici par exemple il y avait
deux sets que je veux calcul et de 0,7
pour un pion et la recette il y avait
donc si les noirs je gardais les décès
de ça c'est mauvais kerouay 6 ans et les
7 17 avec ali 17 vous pour essayer de
sortir en lice mais j'ai plus calmes
allait prendre 17 malgré tout 1 à huy
les cavaliers fuite
oui il reprend la balle et acuité la
tour ne peut plus empêcher la dame mais
en face il y avait un truc mais c'est
plus que ça mais du coup j'ai un peu
assez joli il n'y a pas qu'à l'idée des
scènes plutôt gare de lyon est peut-être
cavalier de saint cyr y vient des 5
je vais peut-être n'y a rien c'est parce
que ces attaques et si on va vous et si
si on va ramasser le pion ème tour 1 7
et 11 jours ou un v8 alors tour à cette
menace tu auras 8
on joue froid revient mais le cavalier
puisque numéro d
trois des huit ça leur bon j'ai
maintenant je suis peut-être obligé de
revenir des tours à quatre ans quelque
chose comme ça j'ai pas mal mais j'ai
pas eu vraiment le temps de tout votre
calculette trois-quatre prochaines coup
il va y avoir calé peut-être si si c'est
que ça a l'air bien des choses comme ça
ewa 24 attaques du fouta classes à
double fond en bessin par exemple entrée
il faut enlever trois comme fram le même
tour aux quatre mois c'est ici c'est ce
oui vous l'avez la tour se recentre plus
menacées visuellement ça allait remettre
bien tout ça a l'air pas mal
mais puisque tours il ya le calcul on
peut être qu'à valider cette halle après
ok bon héros des tours ou quatre cas
validé cet échec 1 ça c'est peut-être
plus projet ici quelque 17 h et voilà en
croisés c'était forcé il peut pas venir
ensuite géré on fera un tour à 8
thuram cela tract est pareil en fait ce
qui est gênant c'est on al'impression
cavalli effet de gan mais
malheureusement pour elle prend je
prends le
parce qu'à tout autre en option
mais ici c'est un bon tour touré cas
aucunement intérêt si ce bon je sais pas
j'ai mal je n'arrive pas à voir
exactement ce que peut-être des perpète
une part plus que la perpétuent richesse
moyenne perpétuelle paris qui avait les
deux des six calice et 5 et celle de
l'échec chèque ou localement avec le
temps c'est vrai que c'était très
compliqué d'être précis dans lequel est
sûre puisque en tous cas là vous êtes
complet mais surtout donc voir des
mythes et elle aurait été le bon coup
est ce qu il a joué je pense que c'est
déjà mauvais et il a des problèmes quand
même après donc c'est on est là voilà
sur 6 il a joué tout prend 1,6 ça c'est
mauvais oui on se rend aussi jouer faut
être quatre la c30 1 puisque pioncer
sept tombes royales mal placé certains
pions - mais beaucoup beaucoup de
compensation on attend des démarches en
fait un psy fait car les drm jour maths
et à domicile se fait malgré un coup à
jouer probablement le bon coup droit b
vite malgré tout tourne france est
menaçant on peut même viser les taux
baisser mais c'est pas terrible
si cette menace plusieurs schémas de
l'échec des découvertes cavaliers des
cinq attaques comme le fou en attaquant
la tour et le fujian obligé de faire
double échec pour ne pas perdre du match
si on fait tout reprend 6 échecs ont
perdu fou et dont il ya aussi tours et
sète qui a l'air joli mais c'est pas bon
tout rêve cet échec avec l'idée de
maintenir ces otages un jour à 8
une journée à 8 g
en prison c'est l'horreur dr d'assen
dans un double échec
cette richesse soit faut joindre à un
seul coup il vient vite exactement
et donc maintenant il est sûr d'avoir
raison de maths
si jamais la tour fait échec que sur la
colonne a c'est vrai parce que là le
sous contrôle je voyais la place en 8es
le cavallino cavani ça donc il est en
cours en fait il est en cours mais il
faut que je perde pas il faut pas que je
perde le fouet et que je mette beaucoup
pour mater ouais donc fou aux 5 ou saas
et je pense que c'était bien joué
voilà et le coût auquel je m'attendais
c'était plutôt et 6 et 10
mais l'idée de faux 5 c'était de retirer
par la suite le fou mais tout en un peu
affaiblissant le front voilà on faire ça
le noir à jouer les psy sont comme ça
aujourd'hui parce que déjà le plus juste
son prix en sicile pas ici parce qu'on
s'y attache à la tva soit d'accord et
donc dans la même position il ya une
fois prises et là je pense qu'il s'est
trompé mais c'est déjà difficile village
autour tours 8
ah oui oui et là il aura vu les tarbais
trois tours bâle iii un temps de trois
menaces matin menace matin à troy à
cause du fou qui contrôlent des 8 es là
il a tout à fait le 17
il devait jouer bien sûr roi 7 à 7 et
comme ça il a une case imbéciles en est
sorti en trois sets je comptais jouer
food et quatrième sur food et 4 mondiale
découverte le fuet emprise donc fort a
lancé bernard ancien mais peut-être
parce qu'il a joué ce site le mieux
parce que après tout des cas je vois pas
ce qu'il fait et il a joué lès tours 7
ça j'ai reçu j'ai eu le temps de
protéger du match n'est il ya fondé 6
décider si c'est pas une question la
tour assez lourd
donc il va parce que là il est menacé
d'un matisse ici là il a toujours la
patte cazenavette madrid et safe
il abandonne ici non non non il a
continuellement ce qui est normal c'est
pas clairement gagnant je veux montrer
la variante quand même non seulement
nous pour éviter le match ne pas perdre
la tour en trois sets mais il ya tomber
vite je pense que la vingtaine v6 mais
de la position était déjà difficile
consiste la très jolie la toîle bloqué
le rond ça va t'aider en fait oui en
voulant éviter le maté le donne et le
matériel
donc il a joué donc qu'est-ce qu'il a
joué il ya le tour d'assas oui il avait
autour de cette idée de la tour mais
contre les cavaliers ont carrément là je
pense que techniquement c'est gagnant
donc j'ai pris compris si je me fous
c'est ce alors que la qualité en plus
mais il a quand même un pion il a
impliqué horrible ce qui fait que c'est
techniquement gagnant je pense que le
fait de leurs ouailles que c'est un
grand nom mais j'ai hésité à jouer juste
elle tout l'été il me reste un corde au
cou donc j'ai voulu jouer un ou deux
coups solides
je savais que ça ne changeait pas la
position même nature de la positivement
les fous c'est certain qu'il a joué faux
au 6 mai qui j'ai joué quatre fini par
me dire que ça va être quand même
intéressant de fixer sur les cases
blanches voilà donc comment voilà
d'autres presque terminé il a joué il
m'a joué cavalier c'est cette cavale et
c'est cette attaque la tour tropez 6
donc là c'est probablement déjà gagnant
comme tomber si ça n'a pas de sens
tout montre le pion s'est on bosse et il
n'y a jamais une forteresse même si le
roi est l autre côté il me fous de ça et
là je me fous des cinq f3 f30ma la f3
pour prendre des 15 août exactement
ramener le roi prendre des cases j'aime
bien quand tu me dis exactement la
sélection de trouver des caravanes et
1,6 alors cavaliers 6 après on saura
assez typique une commande domination
bon là c'est déjà très difficile
alors notez que ici le fou est classique
il domine le cavalier voilà un peu un
truc à savoir quand vous avez des partis
comme ça il m'a joué doit répondre une
cavaliers et fuites qui avaient fort et
16 devra ramener sur une autre case - f2
les deux cavaliers 17 tours b 1
en général il faut garder sur les cases
noires mais bon j'en garde le royaume
est toujours le coupé qui permet trois
oui j'essaye juste ramener le roi et
puis je verrai comment ça se passe il
m'a joué ce qui m'a joué les juifs ou
aux 6 6 mais bon passons ces perdants
donc je peux pas dire c'est une erreur
ou c'est pas une erreur est difficile
mais j'ai trois quatre et activent le
ranger active juan noter que sera donc
est actif alors que celui là les fraises
donc j'essaie de provoquer une faiblesse
à aller le roi avec les pions f et g
et puis après ça peut te permettre à
tous d'avoir un passé à jouer pour pour
les pour le royaume ne sais quoi
m6 pour essayer de garder le roi un
petit peu éloigné en face le roi d'aller
sur les thèses des scènes qui est visuel
que j'ai fini par capituler ligne
fictive en toi un bon ça m'embête est de
laisser le roi mais c'est bon ça va tu
connaisses vous aussi gêna sauvages si
c'est exactement la torah tacle fou il a
décidé depuis qu'il ramasse tous les
tifosi la casse après l'euro
il arrive c'est trop tard food et 5
décès est fou des quatre donc menace
tours 7
m ils abandonnent parce que trop c'est
trop fort tour c'est la ligne que je
calculais c'était c5 tourer 3,7 d'abord
cette campagne pour eux c'est plutôt smc
6 et s'ouvre alors notez qu ici on prend
foule les gens la nation un tour à la
corde et qui si fou n'est pas vraiment
un prix ce n'est pas vraiment prise il
faut qu'ils jouent fous ces six pour
défendre le voilà revenu ou cécile soif
ou c3 jouer calmement et puis piqué un
des pions qui mêle presse française et
j'ai hésité entre les deux fous ces sacs
avaient laissé savoir là parce que ça
rentre ses 7es fouet f3 j'aimerais juste
calculer cette ligne là oui il faut être
trois bon je pense que ça gagne sans
trop de complications sans doute ou et
puis on prend un cavalier aussi ce cas
les 6 et de recettes car l'année t4 mais
juste faire attention quand il ya des
fourchettes ici en cas de production
eroica du g5 pourrait céder d'échangés
et puis 3 4 3 ou 4 voilà et la sai gon
donc il va peut-être vous restez un pion
f nature va tout prendre ça suffit pas
gagné d'accord c'est une belle partie
commun parce que c'est pas possible
c'est jamais facile on a vu qu arsène
contre allende avait classé la qualité
je crois bien il a tenu sa veine du cou
et c'est un minimum et tour contre tours
cavalière cédé 1,4 point au compteur
mais bon c'est une bonne ouverture qui a
rien à dire là-dessus donc bon j'ai
juste réussi à obtenir une position sans
rien probablement mais là ça s'est joué
et puis j'ai réussi à utiliser un petit
peu ce les petits impression qu'il a une
qui les a commises et commenté alors je
crois aussi d'ailleurs tu habites dans
le conte j'habite à lille à lille donc
c'est pas loin
puis les non c'est pas loin voilà donc
c'est effectivement c'est presque on met
dès maintenant
donc l'an dernier tu avais fait déjà un
bon résultat
j'avais fini quatrième j'aurais souhaité
faire mieux mais j'étais pas très
mécontent de mon tournoi mais certes
quatrième ce n'est pas un résultat idéal
quoi donc tu vis plus fort tu vises plus
c'est un championnat je pense que
plupart des joueurs visent la première
place
c'est assez particulier comme tournoi
donc c'est pas juste un petit tournoi et
puis si on est 3e 4e 5e et sachant
prises c'est le titre et qui est en jeu
et puis donc il faut juste ne pas avoir
de regret après le tournoi je suis c'est
de donner le maximum
c'est un titre national ça dure non oui
mais c'est parce que sur les tablettes
d'après rmc c'est toujours bien de
d'espérer de gagner mais on verra bien
mais il reste encore quatre rondes mais
alors a bien aidé à y quatre ans mais
sur deux souhaite le meilleur pour la
suite et c'est bon je crois qu'on
apprécie
photo andré pic que tu sois venu puisque
tu viennes parler au public c'est bien
c'est très chouette et aussi pour la
suite l'équipe de france lui pense
souvent
bon c'est un peu compliqué avec moi
l'équipe de france a donc on verra bien
on verra mais je n'avais pas été
sélectionné cette fois ci bon je
souhaite qu'ils fassent un je crois que
c'est le championnat d'europe c'est ça
ouais on souhaite faire un bon
championnat
peut-être par la suite on verra bien
d'accord mais l'équipe est très forte
donc avec maxime
wen et zola etienne laurent et je crois
que c'est romain et vlad wade a dit cela
à fond mais c'est une très très bonne
équipe il peut faire de très bons
résultats
mais un jour l'équipe de france pourquoi
pas oui pourquoi pas merci beaucoup de 6
grammes dont rien voilà merci pour cette
analyse de table belle victoire en deux
sets où donc je vais vous tuer
maintenant toronto classement tu fais
partie des favoris pour le titre il faut
te préparer maintenant pour la suite ça
va être
merci de l'avoir suivi sur des modèles
tv avec donc tigran gharamian alain ce
cru sur dix ont été vus pour vous merci
beaucoup et donc appeler une prochaine
fois sur damon à tv3